oh now we're gonna go now we're being
professional you're listening to the
dollop on the all things comedy Network
now the way this works is God
each week I Dave Anthony read a story
from American history oh nice my boo oh
boy Wow read it's gotten to you
Gareth Reynolds who has no idea what the
topic is going to be about we usually
don't do anything like this as a matter
of fact I always tell people because we
get a lot of people saying request can
you say this at a live show can you do
this a show can you say this one show
but this one I got and I was like
alright I'm gonna do this one we're
never gonna do another request okay this
is the only one but this one's important
we have a message for a special fan from
someone in their life hey Audrey Audrey
Audrey Audrey Audrey
Adri a dry aside from being a superhero
nerd in a podcast connoisseur you have
been an incredible girlfriend thank you
for always being there to make me laugh
smile and to go on all these crazy
adventures with me you always go the
extra mile to do special things for me
and I always will want to do the same
for you so I've asked your favorite
podcast to ask you something special
Audrey will you go to the prom with Maya
go to the prom with my laundry
everywhere Audrey she said no she better
not oh she does oh my god heads will
roll and called it quote is jam-packed
jammed I'm the [ __ ] hippo God they
look a guarantee but it's good and this
is not gonna come particularly podcast
yay
part confession room now hit him with
the puppy you both present sick
arguments about action no unless he died
my friend
uh that's us the dollop that's right
that's the only things and if you would
like to watch this podcast you can go to
the all things comedy YouTube page and
um just have a finger around my finger
around and you'll find us don't have a
finger um first I will be going on a big
tour this summer in June the 6th to the
8th I will be at good night's comedy
club in Raleigh North Carolina I'll be
at the Vermont comedy club in Burlington
Vermont the 13th through the 15th of
June the 20th through the 22nd of June
I'll be at the comedy attic in
Bloomington Illinois Indiana sorry Dave
shut up I'll be a comedy off Broadway in
Lexington Kentucky 27th 29th of June
I'll be at laughs Boston the 19th and
the 20th in July August dates 9th
through the 11th I'll be at the improv
in Denver Colorado I'll be at the
Fremont Abbey in Seattle Washington was
the evening of the 17th and then comedy
on State Street in Madison Wisconsin I
will be recording an album and I'll be
there that whole weekend from the 22nd
to the 24th so great it's so great
having it fake laughter Gareth
squarespace birthplace is where we keep
all of our secrets Hart Mars our web
lies and secrets Squarespace is of
course a a website a company you can
build your beautiful website on we have
our dollop sources on Squarespace you
have your personal web page on
Squarespace yeah my personal web page on
Squarespace so clearly we like it I
personally chose it because I like the
templates super easy to use yeah it's a
good it's a good company get a website
already yeah yeah well that's not cool
Oh a Squarespace beautiful templates
like I said created by world-class
designers powerful ecommerce
functionality lets you sell anything
online anything uh anything
buthe in legal yes a new way to buy
domains and choose from over 200
extensions built in search engine
optimization free and secure hosting
24/7 war-winning support I'm telling you
Squarespace it's the way to go so head
over to Squarespace comm for free child
and when you raided a lot of street isle
child head over to Squarespace come for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code dog to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com enter
code dollop boom you like that I love it
baby and you're my good boy and the good
baby
I want this free child though we also
bought to you by stamps.com no one
really has time to do the post office
you're busy you got to go through
traffic there's parking and there's also
the line at the post office which no one
really has time to go the post office
you're busy who's got time for all that
traffic parking lugging your mail and
pay why just have the post office and if
you go in there fine it's fine and it's
Sheila she works there she's nice I miss
her cuz I know I do stamps calm right
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer whether you're a small
office sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day stamps comm can handle it all with
ease with stamps calm you get five cents
off every first-class stamp and up to
40% off priority in mail not to mention
it's a fraction of the cost of those
expensive postage meters stamps combos
no-brainer saving you time and money
it's no wonder over 700,000 small
businesses are to use stamps a comma I
do want to mail out all the business
from the podcast sure and it's saved me
tons of time and it's super easy and I
love it and I'm happy yeah and we're all
I'm happy so right now our listeners get
a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment just go to stamps com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in a dollop that
stamps comm enter Oh
mmm
[Music]
Gareth we are also brought to you by joy
bird Julie fired couches furnitures
great couches great
I mean quality yes I think we're both
pretty happy joy bird why go we got a
big chair that I can now sit in with two
dogs and and it's awesome
my wife likes joy bird so much that
after we got the joy bird chair she
ended up getting joy bird for her office
hmm yeah that's how much she enjoyed it
and they helped her out like she had a
like a person all right
concierge every call it like there's a
person on that additional person that
helps her out yeah a person so I highly
recommend it with joy bird you get one
of a kind of furniture made to your
unique taste turn on turn off and turn
your ideas into reality with hundreds of
styles and options for mid-century
modern to contemporary classics
customizable in an array of fabric
choices from rich buttery leather I know
you like butter and flush velvet to
every color imaginable free personal
design consultants to help nail down
your perfect isn't so it's not a
concierge but consultant it's a it's a
person job quality handcrafted furniture
365 day home trial skipped the furniture
store and bring the showroom home sit on
it sleep on it and break it in
long pause there everybody let's not
break this time if you don't love you
joy bird I'm sorry I broke it and
where's my money come back see how joy
board is revolutionising online
furniture shopping create the furniture
that brings you joy today at joy bird
calm stop go to Joburg comm slash stop
and receive an exclusive offer for 25%
off your first order by using code
dollop how'd you know the code gets this
show we are also brought to you by open
fit which by the way I can hook you up
with weed they just said we use the same
password oh really
yeah if you have to mention that but
I've been using it I've been doing it
it's actually they're actually hard to
work out I want that like it's legit
I want no joke work out
you know my old system and I'm good it's
weird if you do like a grandpa thing at
a park yeah everyone you like to see the
Taichi people in the park yeah they're
crazy
yeah that's right there was one right
next to him jumping open frit is
bringing you something new that makes it
even easier to never miss a workout lose
the commute to the gym and let the
workouts come to you so what is it open
if it takes all the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your home in as little as 10
minutes a day and just create and those
10 minute workouts are brutal half -
they really are brutal if you want to be
there's you know different levels
everyone's bodies are different open
forgets that which is why it is
personalized to your needs with custom
tailored original content they have
amazing trainers and classes it's super
simple you can workout to your schedule
access anywhere at any time computer on
a web enabled TV tablet smartphone Roku
you get the deal you can lose up to 15
pounds in just 30 days it's harder with
me because I eat a lot of fudge fudge
eating is not part of the program it's
not on the diet for open fit no but I've
been to have it and I have been losing
weight and and it is like I said it's
legit workout there's tons of different
workouts on there and it's really good
I'm open Fitness change the way I
workout with our code dog you can join
me on a fitness journey personalized
just for you again use our code doll and
start using open fit for your journey to
a healthier life right now during the
open fit 30-day challenge our listeners
get a special extended 30-day free trial
membership to open fit where you can
lose up to 15 pounds in 30 days when you
text up to 30 30 30 you will get full
access to open fit all the workouts and
nutrition information totally free again
just text all up to 30 30 30 30 30 30 30
30 30 30
how many thirties 3 ok
standard messe message and data rates
may apply oh wow that's a that's tough
yeah yeah are people still paying for
text
um I know this stuff to say that but who
pays yeah I guess some people did I
guess some people who do like really you
know bottom-of-the-barrel plans they
can't afford it like a good plan they
probably paid only reason I would do
that would be to like limit texting yep
yeah that's it I would like to limit
texts from you which I did yeah what you
did today what time what time what time
what time what time what time look at
your laughs psyche we have fun oh my god
January 6 1925 year of our Lord Jesus
Christ actually this is the day of our
Lord Jesus this is the word this is the
Easter episode yeah so better be the
year of our Lord this is the name of
Jesus I know this is where he comes from
behind the rock and he's like you
[ __ ] I'm here I never was like
oh [ __ ]
I think he pushed it and memory serves
he pushed it he's like a strong guy he's
Jesus dude he could have walked here he
wanted to no he couldn't
absolutely he's got that sort of skinny
guy rip thing so he comes out and he
pushing these what the [ __ ] and all
these rabbits come out from behind him
yeah and there and then he's there like
Jesus if you want to know where we are
follow the egg trail and then he had to
pick eggs the whole way anyway that's
the dog story of Jesus John DeLorean was
born in Detroit oh [ __ ] yes oh yes his
Romanian immigrant father Zachary worked
as a union organizer at a Ford factory
did not speak great English dad which
kept him from moving up he liked to
drink John DeLoreans father like a sauce
okay and getting into bar fights okay
occasionally punching his wife oh well
now well not super light and fun any
longer oh but God took a dark turn dark
turn a catherine was a Hungarian
immigrant who worked for GE and when
Zachary got violent she would leave with
the kids she started taking them for a
long time more than once she stayed a
year in California with her sister Wow
so that's a lot that point it feels like
is over yeah pretty much
right she finally divorced Zachary in
1942 he moved into a boarding house and
became a drug addict and John never saw
his father again okay so he has a fun
little ending yeah he's got a great yeah
he had a great he yeah grounds and then
blacks out yeah good run right that's
cool John grew up lower middle class
during the Depression he got into an
elite public school Cass Technical High
School mmm Cass Tech it was basically a
feeder into the three big automakers
okay
he seemed set right that's a that's
everyone was trying to get into it like
if you got in then you're gonna make
money at the factory like you're right
you're killing it and while those are
jobs that'll never go overseas that's
right that's right but he also played
the saxophone the school jazz band oh
and that's what he decided he would be a
musician sure so he got into to Cass
Tech and then he was like I'm here for
jazz I like I'm here for make him uh I
just feel the man it's in me sure bass
is in me yeah okay after Cass he got a
music scholarship to Lawrence Institute
of Technology and then he was like I
want to make microwaves that's what I
want to do Borg you graduate he was
drafted in 1943 okay he came back three
years later family was not doing well so
he took different jobs to help them out
okay he finally finished his
undergraduate degree degree and got a
job as an insurance salesman interesting
he said he did this to learn how to talk
to people better okay which yes that's
why you do that sure just talk to people
but okay but also you could just sell
them insurance or they really know how
to be a natural conversation with John
got into a postgraduate facility called
the Chrysler Institute of engineering
okay so the way it was their focus they
focus on Ford cars okay yes it's weird
name was weird so the way that work is
you would work and get an education at
the same time okay
so you're basically getting a master's
while you are
working right so and you're making bang
so oh wow so like I made internship
while you're going to school yeah did
you imagine paying an intern it's hard
it's hard to imagine paying kids in
college anything for their yeah you know
yeah work John got a master's in
automotive engineering okay and then he
went to school at night to get while
he's working at the factory he's going
to school at night gets an MBA from
University of Michigan okay so that was
well as at Chrysler he's not a Chrysler
long before he takes a job at Packard in
research and development
oh sorry he was at Chrysler for a year
after going through the school and doing
all that sure the business 1953 now he's
making the equivalent of a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars today he's like
twenty a super young okay that's cool he
lived with his mom until he married
Elizabeth Higgins in 1954 okay so he's
living at home making 130 it's a great
move yeah great move yeah John was an
alert away by GM hmm Jim offered him his
choice of a job in any of GM's divisions
hmm so they'd rather just like whatever
you want you you mean have a job in any
of our division how many divisions do
they have okay but still this is a
little good amount but it's not like I
know thousand but usually they're like
we have a job available right well right
now it's like pick your now it's just
like you owe me
you eat bolts are you in yes all right
stop crying stop crying
eat screws my other job oh you idiot
what did my third job oh Jesus I'll get
to eating the bolts it's due on food
stamps because the three jobs well you
don't have any room for food in your
belly or full of metallics and less cry
cry more munch munch John pick the
Pontiac division interesting well we own
the funny axe it's still a hot car
that's right every time I see a Pontiac
now I'm like unicorn always turquoise
Jim was the biggest car company on earth
but Pontiac was struggling it had
identity his boss bunkie Knudsen what
just [ __ ] set it blank the guy's name
function bunkie Knudsen the bunk sure he
starts to form a relationship with
NASCAR okay well a lot of bunkies have
connections to NASCAR boom that's right
yeah that's one of the biggest names I'm
sure yeah bunkie liked to say quote you
can't sell an old man's car to a young
man but you can sell a young man's car
to an old man hey bunkie isms
I got bunk talk yeah bunkie is pretty
much the only guy in the car business
thinking this way okay no one was
thinking about selling cars to young
people cars were big and they drove
smooth and Detroit guys could not
imagine why anyone would want anything
different right surrett they're just
those big boats that just [ __ ] feel
like you're riding on glass right this
was known as the Detroit mind okay
became known as the Detroit mind John
became successful at Pontiac in 1961
Bernie became long funky became general
manager at Chevrolet and at 36 John
became division chief engineer at
Pontiac okay
after work the engineers would test
drive prototypes that would never ever
make it to a dealership interesting
Woodward Avenue became a drag strip so
they're just trying out different types
of cars that are never gonna be any
that's pretty fun GM prohibited the
production of high-performance cars that
alluded to racing or high speed Wow yeah
different time so they would not the the
goal was really more stability and
dependability like something that's fun
right yeah something I want to put
flames on that's right right and January
1963 a memo came out stating Jim cars
were banned from racing activities so
they must have heard about the ready
after our racing drag race right GM cars
had to weigh at least 10 or more pounds
per cubic inch of engine displacement so
that would mean they would not be fast
enough a ray
okay they actually had a mejor mullah to
wait the cars down so they wouldn't so
they would not be fun yeah okay so your
parents design cars now that's right
but John started to wonder what would
happen if you took a big v8 engine
uh-huh made for a full-sized car and you
put into a smaller car sure it turns out
it's a super-fast very powerful very
drivable car with the head of Pontiacs
approval john snuck the engine past the
GM engineering policy committee by
selling it as a package for the 1964
tempest so cars are going out uh-huh and
then or you put in an order for a car
and they don't notice that he's like
putting this engine into a smaller car
okay which they're totally engine
smuggling yeah basically he's engine
smuggling he's he's I think they call it
hiding the engine sure in the business
sure he's pulling a fast engine oh he's
pulling a fast engine so he calls it the
GTO package so you go the dealership you
go I want the GTO package and they throw
in effect yeah sit down sit will be a
minute he took he took the name from
Ferrari this is the first muscle car Wow
they sold 5000 before GM figured out
what was going on and they're just
they're thinking they're just like it's
a package for a car they're not no one's
paying attention to the fact because
it's an edict you don't put that I have
you don't put that in the car yeah
muscle cars immediately became big
sellers the Chevy Chevelle the Dodge
Charger that Barracuda followed GM
invented the muscle card and then Ford
took it over the Mustang came out it
sold 1.5 million in two years Wow so
it's the [ __ ] thing right for
defining the company policy and creating
a neat car John became the youngest
division head in 1960 yeah that is what
you do right yeah we are [ __ ] furious
at your behavior John how dare you
here's your new office and well done
really thank you for not listening to
our [ __ ]
whoa that's him huh I think that's
bunkie oh that's bunkie may
the tiger suits what does that even mean
I thought that could be him that st.
John well that says its DeLorean yeah
that might be that might be him when
he's in the CIA he's gonna change a lot
so that's why hmm
that'll throw you off so uh so he's
young right for having all of this power
ready for and we stir t6 I'm still young
or the position he's in he became he
becomes the youngest division head in
1965 okay there was a lot of fighting
between division heads a jam and it
didn't help that the young guy who broke
the rules was now an equal to the older
guys who paid their dues age you can see
yeah oh my god
the guys who I've just wanted the car to
drive slowly diode and then this [ __ ]
comes along blows everything out of the
water here we go what is DeLorean have
for us now he's an equal Pontiac pushed
GM limits on advertising one campaign
they came up with was to embraced Tigers
so that's the tiger suit that's right
headline but what does that mean
embraced tiger dealers gave out orange
and black license plates and Tiger tails
to be hung on antennas or on the back
license plate [ __ ] cool bug that is
the first GTO commercial in 1965
featured a tiger jumping out from under
a hood yeah by the way not a great gig
for the tiger actor okay not an actor
actual tiger and and then to make this
commercial you have to get the tiger in
the hood and close the hood right so to
do that they ended up using 40 pounds of
raw meat in the commercial well that'll
give me in a car so they throw 40 pounds
of meat in and the Tigers like alright
I'll do your goddamn commercial I think
probably the animals they don't know
they're filming me no they have no idea
you're just like this is torture
I love the meat until you get 40 pounds
of meat and fall Pontiac won the Motor
Trend Car of the Year award
next the ad team had G a GTO jumping a
small gully in an ad and the other side
a goalie going a gully different goalies
very different that's yeah weirder so
the now the other heads of the jam
divisions are furious because there
showing like [ __ ] daredevil fresh
[ __ ] yeah and then John was told to find
a more responsible way to sell the car
the GM chairman
besides tigers and gully leaps well the
GM chairman said no more Tiger
comparisons sure it's too aggressive
right three years of Tiger promotions
were dead they started calling the gto
the great one in ads okay so back then
so now they get Wayne Gretzky now they
go in Gretzky so now back then Detroit
car executives are celebrities Wow
because it's the biggest company going
right and then if you get that position
you're a super-powerful guy yeah you're
just known yeah yeah sure and John like
now yeah exactly
well then we all know we go name the gym
hell yeah yeah nobody wants to put their
heads on pikes
well Oh John so John's a big celebrity
he's a young guy he invented the muscle
car he has access to 40 pounds of meat
20 times Molly rebel that's right go go
go horrible mm-hmm
magazines write articles about him he
became known as the exec who understood
youth right he gets the kids he gets him
and he remade himself in that image he
quit smoking lost weight grew out his
sideburns dyed his hair black wore
turtlenecks bell-bottoms and a peace
symbol on a necklace hmm okay so he's a
costume shop
well GM is a very conservative place so
that's not him that's the picture of
somebody else okay
GM is a very conservative place so it's
weird that he is doing that that's him
no dress this is more what is and there
he is just doing some chest oh this is
something from a magazine chest workouts
oh wow okay so he's he's just on a bench
with a couple of dumbbells to work in
the pecs without a shirt on no shirt so
Jim's very conservative corporation
everyone wears a suit and then there's
got this guy who's just doing
Pech work when John was out of the
office he had his shirt unbuttoned down
to the middle of his torso he got a
facelift whoa and an implant to reshape
his jaw Jesus Christ
yeah he's [ __ ] John I don't know he's
killing it sounds like he's got some
demons um yeah well this might be a
middle life midlife crisis situation I'd
say he told Fortune magazine he had
reconstructive surgery after going
through a windshield in a car wreck I
was the hopping over a gully that had a
tiger in the engine and it's imagine a
to do it and then he and then when they
checked on the racetrack he said he got
Nate mm-hmm the rich I grana was like
yeah that didn't happen right that's
what you got to do or at least that's
what you had to do when you had plastic
surgery back then right you kind of came
up with a facial alibi yeah
facial alibi all right so so reporters
reporters would come to his home like he
would just invite reporters in he wants
to show everybody how he's living you
know he's very accessible to the press
he'd drive reporters to work while
blasting Jefferson Airplane yeah he does
fake John faceless normal you talk about
them you know what hate makes you
smaller any other race you guys um are
you sure your joys and hey fine I got an
accident as their race track yeah you
look normal like I look normal I am
normal yeah one pill makes you larger
blood period makes you smile then the
wounded matter gives you was you ready
so he'd also talked about the Beach Boys
quote French philosophers and talk about
historian Peter gays writings on human
misery he told one report he was writing
a novel about nuclear war he also loved
to show off his abs
so he's a little late Leon muskie right
yes right I mean it's just sort of like
very llama especially the way the press
is treating yeah and he's not he's like
he's no longer behind the scenes so now
he's leading into the absurdity of the
character that is sort of he said he
didn't understand why auto execs felt
they had to vote Republican and he
studied FM rock radio to get intel on
the Love Generation what did he studied
FM radio do you ever study FM radio no
it's been a while if you want to know
the kids why don't we fly repealed FM
reporters just sucked up what he said
the local press not as taken as the
National one paper ran a gospel article
about an anonymous autoexec who got
plastic surgery mmm who was it huh they
never sent an anonymous John Elizabeth's
marriage fell apart in 1960 I can't
believe I'm still married oh I was gonna
say I can't believe they got divorced no
I can't believe she hung in there with a
new jaw new face new attitude always
lifting weight he's awesome yeah he
sounds a little okay she sued him for
cruelty and she got the house and she
showed reporters bills from a plastic
surgeon in Switzerland that kept coming
in the mail man you just pay right away
one lump sum you got the money yeah no
you know what these Swiss face bills
chasing you for the rest of your life
that's right I've been there John then
started spending time in California not
good
Popular Mechanics quote John would
descend the steps from the jamb
corporate plane with his sunglasses on
and his coat over one arm ready to party
is an accurate description Erin Erin air
dude he dated Ursula Andress Candice
Bergen Nancy Sinatra and Raquel Welch
Wow Jesus
racquel washes fairly attractive Raquel
Welch is an attractive person is Bergen
he lose I'm not familiar with there
really who was the other first one
Ursula Andress who's I think she was a
Bond girl she's she's a fairly Nancy
Sinatra I know her I know yeah boots
remember walking here right that's it I
said did something yep yeah so he's
hanging out with big stars at executive
members-only nightclubs it's just so
Elliott Musk this is so GM classic G
yeah some weeks he flew out to
California on a Thursday and went head
back to Detroit on a Tuesday
pretty good sched one time he tossed a
junior exec lipstick and said nachi
Sinatra wanted a Firebird that color and
to do it in four days bubbly so he's
getting a little less losing the plot a
little losing the plot at the opposite
touch so so he falls in love again okay
1969 okay this time with Kelly Harman
huh her dad was a college football
legend war hero and sportscaster okay
her brother would become known as actor
Mark Harmon oh wow yeah alright so it's
a it's a family right it's a it's a
bel-air rich family oh wow well this
Harmons this is a better run I got
stupid do like Oh God with the dog yeah
he's got his turtleneck on he looks like
the turtleneck he's wearing is made from
the dog uh so she's 20 he's 44 do you
bring up that your wife got a house out
of a cruelty suit to your new love hey
well she's 20 how you know what are you
guys talking about at all
that's true they married at the bel-air
Country Club John wrote a song for Kelly
that the Robert Mitchell Mitchell boys
choir sang Kelly told the reporter quote
I like riding skiing waterskiing music
swimming poetry parties and dogs she's
20 yep
yep that sounds like a twenty-year-old
list John start starts driving a
Maserati instead of a GM car I said
interesting maybe made a number eyes why
not okay
yeah I'm sure GM was like cool hey John
you know
Saturday and Sunday are the days off we
have we been clear they adopt a son
named Zachary okay
his dad had died the year before John's
dad okay I died the year before throat
cancer
and after the Ford factory called John
and asked him to come pick up his dad's
toolbox Jesus but that's also like Ford
being yeah who wins there yeah I don't
know who wins but like you're calling
like the head of a division of Jim hey
come pick up your duster but still yeah
hopefully you don't weep all over them
both Kelly and John dislike to Detroit a
social life okay they told the reporter
they'd rather go on a moonlight
horseback ride than go to a Bloomfield
Hills cocktail party Kelly starts
spinning there's other options no that's
it Oh you either go on a nighttime horse
ride horse ride in the moonlight or you
go to the Bloomfield Hills cocktail
parties there's nothing in between okay
it just seems like that's it there's a
movie no that's what we got dancing by
the way it wasn't Detroit like the [ __ ]
back then yeah so they were just like
now just a lot of money in Detroit back
then yeah same as now mmm Kelly's start
spending more and more time in
California without John that's not a
good sign he's the gateway yeah none of
this slowed down John's career at GM the
new model Camaro is due out next year
and it was behind schedule and redesigns
for the Corvette and Nova were lacking
okay Nova yeah so over the past four
years they've been a lot of bad
publicity from recalls and other issues
so John was put in charge of the
Chevrolet Division it's a big division
bump yeah
by 1971 Chevrolet had sales of over 3
million cars Hey
division alone was almost as much as
olive fort well that's how much he's
sawing so he's him right he's good he's
good at his job okay but he's also party
boy a bit of a dish a bit of a dish
yeah in between he's flying to LA and
his ex-wife got a house because of his
cruelty that's a yeah that's a bad word
it's not good yeah so he's flying to LA
he's Hannah was Sammy Davis jr. Johnny
Carson I love your crazy cars babe but
take your I your cars are so wild I
can't believe you got a tiger in the
hood of one of them that's just nuts is
that Kherson yeah he started looking for
more ways to make money he bought a
piece of the San Diego charges and he's
I'm I'm trying to receiver just a little
bit and the New York Yankees okay he was
put on boards of startups getting
involved with other businesses really
did not go over well at GM he's supposed
to only care about he's like a one-man
shark tank
like in GM world they're like this is
all you would ever want to I mean he's
killing it he is killing it so you would
think that that would be true he's
making shitloads of money he's he's very
successful
yeah but he still want yeah he wants
more Kelly and John split in 1972 Saudis
won't come I did not you wrote it a
magazine photographer came to his house
and took pictures of John wandering
around hisses oh that let me get my
dumbbells wearing nothing but jeans hot
I mean let me get my dumbbells yeah so
he's he's kind of making the divorce did
he marry Kelly yeah they were married oh
okay
I remember he had it he sang her song I
didn't know I thought that was just like
dates sick [ __ ] no that was though that
was the marriage it's a big clam but but
he's like he's like taking the divorce
and making it into a like a publicity
thing like for him like I'm sad I'm
walking around without my shirt on I
can't even face my shirts anymore what
do I do
I got nothing just these jeans and a
dream
just the jeans and a dream oh blam I
couldn't yeah I look for him earlier but
I couldn't find any pictures of him just
shirtless in jeans so we've got that
dumbbell one so he said obviously John
won custody Zachary his friends in
Hollywood treated him to a weekend in
Malibu with three sex workers who looked
like Kelly that's that's nice friends
that's nice friends to get three Kelly's
three Cal weekend for the guy yeah
that's sweet
that's friends it's called being a nice
guy yeah some friends would probably
just want to be emotionally supportive
man you know here you can get readable
gangers will bang you that's right
doppel bangers yeah the hell would I do
that
classic GMO stuff that's in the handbook
yeah for sure I'm sure they're happy to
hear that guy hey John it's Wednesday
where you been sorry I was Bing in three
almost Kelly's all weekend anyway what
new car do I need to put a tiger in a
friend quote he said it was the
classiest thing anyone had ever done for
him so he doesn't know what class that
was his phrase classy classy
he also said no one in Detroit had
enough class to do something like that
nobody in Detroit is this classy as you
get there's no way anybody in Detroit is
gonna buy me an escort that looks
exactly like my wife that's just classic
that's classy Detroit would never do
that they're not classy they don't get
it that's same here John was on a plane
when he saw model and actress Christine
Farrar in Vogue magazine okay he toured
the five-page spread out and put it in
his brief so if you're sitting next to
him like oh he's gonna murder oh he's
going to murder that model for sure
so quote I felt a bit sheepish like a
teenager with a crush on a movie star
yeah you're a [ __ ] weirdo putting
pictures in your pants well briefcase
but why my briefcase is normally in my
pocket I'm sorry I'm thinking of a
wallet
classic me so
she's 22 he's 48 but he's like this is
the this is the hot hot girl for me
mm-hmm normal it's normal stuff yeah
well by the way let's go how dating apps
are essentially so he's got he's ahead
of time he's he's got a crush 42 year
guy with a crush on 22 year old yeah by
the way it's not like you rip out one
picture sure you can get away with
saying it's the perfume or something you
rip out five you are a psychopath you
remember oh yeah what do I know her from
she she's some movies but you probably
just know her from her modelling way
yeah I know her from her Max Factor
that's right so he's now John is now
promoted again he is now execs are of
cars he is now exec in charge of GM's
North American car and truck division so
he's the [ __ ] [ __ ] right but with all
the success he still feels empty sure he
told his tank Sonny
he told author Gail Sheehy quote here I
was spending my life bending the fenders
a little differently to try and convince
the public they were going to get a new
and dramatically different product I'm
sorry
does he have car block he has is that
what we're like Carmel Avis Yeah right
but he's painting this is like he's got
some sort like it's not block he's
saying like he doesn't feel yeah but I'm
not creatively stimulated any men just
bending fenders that's just pulling one
over on the public again what gross
excess it was ridiculous I thought
there's got to be more to life than this
am i doing the thing God would have me
do here on earth excuse me John is it
true you ripped out five pictures of a
woman on a plane God wanted me to do
that
okie-dokie God wants me to jerk off when
I'm back in the hotel John John you're
on Mike I know well we're gonna end the
interview with you I'm gonna take off my
shirt keep it on you [ __ ] mmm Jesus
Anna these jeans are tighter than
yeah no they're too tight for sure tight
like a v8 engine in a tempest your idea
was the door fellow Joe your fellow GM
execs did not like John yeah he talked
too much in interviews the way he
dressed was unprofessional he made no
friends at GM during his rise one of his
bosses at jam warned him now that he had
made it to the executive floor so this
this move put him on the so now you've
got the guys like all right literally
it's the 14th floor he made it on the
powerful right
so this exec warns him now that he's
there he should quote disappear into the
wallpaper hmm [ __ ] play cool man you
made it you made it you're on the 14th
floor Johnny boy
play it cool go live in the wall John
was to give a speech at a GM conference
about quality control on how it affects
GM's bottom line okay days before the
conference the speech was leaked to the
Detroit News papers across the country
ran the story the New York Times
headline was quote GM warns its
executives to improve Auto quality
mmm-hmm John so it makes it sound like
he's talking [ __ ] about the quality
right John screamed that he had been
double-crossed so a GM GM hired a
private investigator to look into it and
into John buy enough more than you could
chew here right yeah is this you've
asked for too much I want to know who
did it well we're gonna investigate the
company and you you know what let's call
this we're good a guy it's just a speech
I'm a guy I'm I'm gonna take my shirt
off shirt for sure that's the first
order of business as the shirt is coming
off in September 1972 John Lee John
finally met the girl he had selected out
of a Vogue magazine like it was a menu
he met Christine at a Gucci show but she
was dating another rich guy it turns out
hmm someone had ripped her magazine
clippings out a little too quickly
that's right
luckily that rich guy died when he
crashed his plane near Santa Barbara
John waited a month or so then asked
Christine to lunch for sure you gotta
give that time period and it's also a
month and a lunch yeah
soif berry you don't want to do a
two-week and dinner in her [ __ ] you
do a month in a lot she'll go get crazy
purse you look like a psycho Matt Hyde
your psychosis that's right you do a
month and a lunch John said he quote
wanted Christine for Christmas so he's
now what the devil is that fair
[Music]
the pi2 Liberty his 19 page report on
John in early 1970 hey so GM is pretty
fine
John's a psychopath John's [ __ ] crazy
John's crazy John put your shirt on I
can't I don't have any
it contained quote certain allegations
about John's personal life okay and it
said the person probably responsible for
leaking his speech to the press was John
was John GM announces John's resignation
in April 1973 mm-hmm the company never
said a word about why he left even to
this day they've never said why he left
his bonuses were paid he was put in
charge of a non-profit Geum ran that way
he could keep some salary okay and given
a Cadillac dealership in Florida okay
three weeks after being let go John
married Christine Jesus oh sorry yeah
there you go so I was I being too happy
was the or offense I care about this and
since Jim never said anything about why
he left John was able to control the
story okay he became the guy who fired
GM oh yeah right and walked away from
assess how it works yeah employees fire
the business all the time right he was
the guy who walked away from a $650,000
job cuz he wanted to move to Florida
yeah but this new magazine woman his
kids he went on the lecture circuit and
wrote opinion pieces he was the car
business guy and took the old guy
old guard to task for their refusal to
change sure it was perfect timing as the
OPEC oil embargo hit and everyone
wondered why America only made huge cars
right so he's the man of the [ __ ]
hour okay
Jonathan connected with a former car
salesman
Roy Nassif whose office was just a pay
phone at a bar that's man don't you long
for those days oh my god are you doing
it's right yeah yeah oh yeah I'll get it
hold on it's not for me hello Roy's car
business
yeah it's also a bar okay yeah now we're
open till midnight
all right hello Roy here car business a
lot of color for him that's the beauty
of this man okay yeah we got a bunch of
potato chips for sale behind the bar a
quarter each yeah I'm also a car guy Roy
I wonder if we can find him what's his
name Roy Nassif yep
Oh Roy oh whoa which one is he see all
of them oh there it is looks like you
answers a phone at a bar like it says so
so they team up they start working on
deals together okay a car dealer let
John buy into his dealership and then he
watched as John and Roy just ran up huge
debts against the business the dealer
ended up walking away from his own
business these guys fired GM hey
[ __ ] the dealer quote DeLorean uses
mystique to put the deal together and
then he puts the rape in the guy is a
demon underneath I tried to tell people
but I gave up talking because nobody
would listen I mean giving up talking is
frustrating so that sounds like what the
mob does they come into a business then
they load it with dad or press the money
or precedent yeah that's
I'm a car Clinton everyone since Reagan
that's right
Christina and John were having trouble
making a baby so she visited in New York
palm reader an advisor named Sonia Sonia
put a glass of tap water under
Kristina's chair at the beginning of the
session at the end of the session she
retrieved it it was full of blood what
just happened
blood glass she put a glass of sorry
this is the tap water and put it class
doesn't matter if it's from the tap well
we put it under her chair or the chair
and then when she was done with her
session the tap water but blood blood
okay so I see you can see it sounds like
Detroit's water is it too premature I
know but you can see the what's going on
yes she's a basically a doc doctor yes
for shows yes the psychic yeah this is a
this is a person who's a medically
trained mm-hmm individual that's how you
know now drink the blood Cris now drink
the blood you'll be pregnant with a baby
so okay so yep she's good at what she
does
Christina went home and asked John for
ten thousand to give Sonya because she
was gonna help her get pregnant
sure so he did it great and by the way
I'll let you know if any of this sounds
crazy you got it okay and Christina is
sure enough got pregnant
sure Yeah right great yeah after they
had a daughter John started seeing Sonya
privately oh boy what's wrong I feel
like he's you know being John so burning
people was a pattern with Roy and John
there were others like an investor in
Phoenix a rancher in Idaho so they're
just kind of sucking money out of people
while doing all this John planned his
big return to the automobile business
the chief stylist of the Lamborghini
drew him up plans for the dmc-12
it looked like nothing else out there a
rear-engine car with wing doors and a
stainless steel body
it still is the car that if you see it I
am like oh my God look at it I still
can't believe its existence yeah totally
it is like it's like if cocaine made a
car that's right yeah he also want to go
not a lot of people know that actually
what happened was he put a glass of
water under his chair and when he got up
there was a DeLorean that's right the
DMC and blood I've learned a ton of
blood a lot so much blood he was also
adamant that golf clubs would fit in the
trunk great so I got a really good car
designer he told the designer engines in
the back yeah rear engine like a Porsche
right right he told this designers quote
this car is aimed at a particular
section of the market me the horny
bachelor who's made it yeah yeah baby
starting a new car company very
difficult no independent car maker had
taken on GM and survived since the 1920s
ok so no bank would give him money
because it's just a crazy idea ok in
September 1978 DeLorean research got
12.5 million from investors ok people
like Sammy Davis jr. I'm an bap singer
Roy Clark hey Who am I and and the
chairman of Pan Am airlines boy come for
the impression stay for the confusion
the money was moved through Swiss banks
and they come always not jaded and and
then a company based in Panama perfect
the two best way to do it go offshore
best places for money at the Bahamas
involved already he was supposed to the
money was supposed to go to Lotus cars
who an hour helping design DeLorean but
only a hundred thirty-seven thousand
made it it's a lot that didn't no one
notices at the time that the money has
disappeared because really who's keeping
track of it investors gave money they
wouldn't know right
so John turns to governments to try to
build a factory ok in 1970
eight he signed an agreement to build a
factory on an old Air Force Base in
Puerto Rico okay
yeah and celebrated because this is a
big [ __ ] deal sure did a car company
to build the factory sure and then John
announced that he gotten a better offer
from the UK and Puerto Rico is out okay
instead he would build this car factory
in Northern Ireland in Dunmurry
just outside of Belfast okay the land
that he was given was between two
housing developments one Twinbrook was
mostly full of Catholics who were driven
out of Belfast by sectarian violence the
other side full of Protestants so the
cracker would be right in between them
perfect and then sign that lease get
your get the ink on the lease now the
deal was done by the Labour government
along with the National Irish
Development Agency the company we get
150 million dollars okay so the British
and and the Irish are like we're gonna
we're gonna get people jobs right
unemployment is [ __ ] crazy bad at
this point sure in Ireland which is also
great for IRA recruitment and and just
[ __ ] troubles in general right
perfect John told a fellow carmaker
quote I'm starting to think that God
stuck me here to be part of the solution
to the crisis in Northern Ireland
absolutely healthy fall absolutely very
healthy yep God did god yep hey just
build your crazy car I think I'm here to
help these people John Kane - Don Murray
came to Don Murray to break ground on
the factory on October 2nd 1970 they'd
already broken the ground with bombs but
as as he and a member of the Labour
Party dug holes a chain-link fence held
back protesters who chanted Brits out
and Yankee go home
it's not it's all fine it's not
welcoming yeah it's good ok construction
began soon after but the Irish laborers
did not want to cut down a small
Hawthorn tree because they said it was a
fairy tree hmm
who do we root for
the cat caught at one down she's a
fairly tree but let's make the factory
here no we've just harvested her
according to legend if someone cut down
a fairy tree he would lose a limb okay
so that's a great reason to not do it
let him do it lose the limb so all the
bulldozers so they're building the
factory but all the bulldozers and
trucks
everything's avoiding this one Hawthorn
tree okay then all the workers show up
one morning and the tree was gone and
the Irish workers said quote bad sign
it's a dark day you have wrecked
everything we're building the fairy tree
we'll see to that
sure okay in January 1979 The Wall
Street Journal wrote a story out of the
headline taking on Detroit
John DeLorean says he'll show industry
how to build cars
so the Dunmurry factory opened in 1980
it had separate entrances for Catholic
and Protestant workers Jesus that's the
best kind of factory it just feels like
it's ripe for problems John was not a
fan of Belfast and was worried he'd be
abducted or killed well he lost the
fairy tree that's right
once he took down the fairy tree all
bets are off oh it's like a Tales from
the Crypt there were a lot of
businessman being kidnapped then in
Belfast and he told them he told his
staff to get him a bulletproof trench
coat because he heard Kissinger had one
yeah that's the guy you want to be
following what did Kissinger have you
give me that he often flew and slept in
London instead of staying in Northern
Ireland oh my god the company rented two
floors and a Park Avenue building in New
York John's office had a view of Central
Park he having a huge photo of himself
it's always a good time big poster sized
photo okay
he's shirtless in jeans what a douche
Jesus Christ sitting on a rock with his
son ah looking at the ocean jump in it
it sounded like the photographer just
captured him naturally was a shocker
yeah yeah all right John took 78,000
from the company to move his family to
New York Detroit they found a
comfortable 20 room
apartment on Fifth Avenue sure just sure
to enough for three no 20 yes said yeah
exactly
router room just under 7 per person I
think better in bedroom kitchen dining
room yeah spare room wait room their own
shirt red shirt room jeans room blood
chair room pictures of myself remove
yourself pictures of things that I want
to do yeah inspiration room yeah blood
blood blood glass room yeah yeah I think
very true the place where all the fairy
trees install Leland leopard limbs yeah
probably den hide in some of the
bearskin rug so accounting company
Arthur Andersen was hired to audit the
business and found nothing amiss well
it's time for them to go out of business
well Anderson would later go down as
part of the Enron Enron implosion oh
good stomping ground the car company
paid for chauffeurs servants cars for
Christine and her brother and in art
collection and the British are paying
for all of this so part of the hundred
fifty million they put down but then
Margaret Thatcher was elected oh the
Iron Lady Thatcher had no interest in
helping the working man and absolutely
no interest in helping Belfast right
John Hardy I'm a bit of a [ __ ] oh yes
we've never had you on the podcast well
I'm like Reagan the lady yeah hey yes I
hate everything about hate you hey I
don't like shame chamber it's not funny
uh I don't like the way you just killed
entire towns of humans no stop
enough and the Falklands really oh good
lord
get over it John hired a British
secretary to try to smooth things over
the government's hire someone who's
familiar with the processes hey sweet
baby don't get me a shirt hey it's me
Johnny D but William Haddad one of
John's execs said John was losing
John often thought an IRA hit squad was
coming for him and he asked Haddad to
put him in contact with Israeli
intelligence because he had a plan to
seize Saudi oil field holy [ __ ] those
dots barely connect good God so he wants
he's worried the IRA is coming after him
so he gets involved with Israeli army
people in order to take over Saudi oil
field once you do it's called being a
businessman I just wanted to cut down
the goddamn fairy trees
he kept ass also asking about that
bulletproof trenchcoat where's that
technology that we barely don't have you
guys watch there the Bond guy right
right one of them jackets come on
they're gonna throw hats at me that'll
cut my head off if we're not careful
John talked to fewer and fewer people
there was only one person he really
trusted John Sonja the palm reader what
I think I thought my answer was crazy
he consulted her before he made every
big decision she took his money and told
him everything would be okay great what
a great gig for like a psychic oh the
best yeah yeah do that sign this and
here and here in night today the
American Express Christmas catalog
included an $85,000 gold limited edition
DeLorean so they they sent out their old
DeLorean
so this send it out in the catalog and
say that you can get a gold DeLorean
only a hundred or offered a hundred
people only two people bought one oh my
god what but $85,000 back then like he
had a Porsche for a Porsche for the 20s
it still you would think a hundred
people would buy I mean you're talking
like that's like it compared to be like
a $250,000 car some DeLoreans began
leaving the factory to be sold in the US
in April 1981 the car did not live up to
John's promises okay it was not
groundbreaking ly safe or as
fuel-efficient as he said it would be
well he hasn't put in the time-traveling
device yet I
give him time I don't know what the
time-traveling device is it's the flux
capacitor I don't know it you know it's
the only way to get 1.21 jigowatts oh
that a bolt of lightning do you
seriously know this dude that movie
raised me okay come on so there it is
obviously it is quite a lump of [ __ ]
even though I would still love to have
one it looks like a it looks like a bug
yeah it's got way looks like it must
have looked old when it came out people
like wait years no that's that's how
awesome that's how cars look back then
like that's like a modern-looking sorry
boxy
the doors are they'll were it's very
cool I don't care what anyone says all
cars back then like boxy and lame and
okay so although you probably couldn't
Park it in like a grocery store parking
why because the doors right the doors
just go straight up oh they do yeah okay
they don't come out sideways I know I
come it also doesn't have much power and
it doesn't handle very well okay so a
lot of good things a viewer in Cleveland
Auto Show got in to the DeLorean and
then got trapped for over an hour
because the doors wouldn't open still
he's like better than being inside
Cleveland there is a flaw that really
hurt battery life Jesus Johnny Carson's
car died right after he drove it off the
lot I couldn't believe it I might be
Sammy Davis and for all this the price
is the same as luxury cars because it
costs so much to make write this it's
the exact same price as a decent Porsche
okay
they sell okay in the UK the secretary
he hired to deal with the government
started to sour on John and think the
things weren't right hmm in the middle
of the night she filled up two bags of
office documents and skipped out the
documents painted the picture of a
company mismanaging the British
government's money one memo accused an
exec of spending thousands at her odds
on gold-plated faucets Jesus Ben Carson
it's not good but it's also very like
dot-com boom
[ __ ] like that's totally what people are
doing in the dot-com boom right era the
plan was to take the car company public
so that's these documents this would
have made John a hundred and twenty
million and leave people with stock
options like execs and dealers with
close to nothing I don't know how this
[ __ ] works
I don't need basically right yeah it's
it's like you know replacing a glass of
tap water with blood that's right right
the British government would lose the
seat sat on the board which meant it
would not be able to watch what was
happening with the money Britain would
get three point six to the company and
eight point four million for 150 million
dollar investment so the secretary took
the docks to a Tory MP in London but
nothing happened cool sounds like the
Tories hey secretary waited four weeks
and then finally she talked to a
reporter and the reporter began
investigating but the news of the world
killed the story hmm what year it's 80
the reason the news of the world killed
the story was because Rupert Murdoch
ordered them to oh wow
turns out Rupert lives in the same
building as the DeLoreans Oh God
Rupert said he didn't know John though
he sometimes thought Christina in the
elevator so the reporter sold the story
to the Daily Mirror instead he's like
the Forrest Gump of evil right I would
love to I would love to run a simulation
where you see what the planet is like if
Murdoch died all be shirtless so he
sells the story of the daily reporter
and Rupert the guy Rupert the guy who
didn't know John DeLorean then
immediately gave John the name of a
really tough libel lawyer which is weird
for a guy you don't know but whatever
yeah whatever yeah just being neighborly
it's like a cup of sugar in that
building John started working his press
connections he attacked the secretary of
the reporter and anyone else who was
saying anything
the press what wrote what he wanted
that's right the press loves him right
he said he would see the reporter in the
Daily Mirror for 250 million Thatcher
cuts off any more funds no you're done
you're cut off just like all the coal
miners in Scotland you're not having any
more you don't get any you eat your meat
if you don't get it he put him you can't
eat your meat no that's not a song it's
something like that no it's a dead part
was not at all what is that this is a
sign about the ad minutes just to make
in the streets our voice them there's an
emergency word it's me mags you know hmm
Scotland Yard investigated quaff I'm not
Queen Victoria but worse
Scotland Yard investigated and found
nothing what is going on but the damage
was done the stock offering had been
delayed
John was everything on the up and up I
mean no okay the stock offering was
delayed John's dream of making 120
million is gone I mean he is making cars
the factory is churning right the
company is now out of money on February
19th 1982 DeLorean Motor Cars was put
into receivership mmm which means that
it's time for them to talk to the people
who can finish it was still functioning
while the government figured out if any
part of the business could be salvaged
so there's no making cars but there it's
just not government's in charge
basically and and they're trying to
figure out what the [ __ ] to do right the
government brought in an expert whose
nickname was the Undertaker oh good good
good good
John talked to the New York Times and
said he was quote delighted by the news
we came out largely unscathed the
government has
the problem and we have the fun end of
the business I trust the Undertaker John
said it was going to wipe a hundred
thirty million off the company books The
Undertaker's said that was quote
codswallop
oh yes finally someone yes codswallop
that's I should be our spin-off podcast
codswallop that's bloody codswallop so
obviously this is huge news all over the
place right and a man named James
Hoffman was paying attention Hoffman was
a federal informant who'd gotten about
$32,000 in salary from the feds to make
cases against cocaine dealers okay
he was now watching the news and seeing
John DeLorean Dallara him squirm and he
used to know John he had lived near
John's ranch in California okay
one day Hoffman said it was DEA escort
that he was going to deliver them John
DeLorean the agent didn't believe him
Hoffman got mad and just kept on the
agent he would deliver John DeLorean
over the next month
The Undertaker kept trying to set
deadlines and John delayed him by saying
he had found an investor uh-huh
and it was always for the same amount 30
million at one point the Undertaker said
quote surely to God you could find the
grace to vary the figure every now and
then if only for appearances
[Laughter]
if you're going to lie to me at least
Pryda lie to me John went to Sonja and
gave her more money she said to keep the
faith so he knew would be fine sure yeah
because that psychic in Miami said so
John was now at doing drugs what he was
taking sent a call to sleep and a
painkiller that was only legal in Canada
sure he kept calling investors trying to
get someone to bite then on June 29th
John got a call from James Hoffman okay
he offered to hook John up with
investors Hoffman later said they were
good friends and John said they had only
met once in a driveway so the two men
met in
a bar in Newport Beach and after that
meeting the FBI opened a file on John
DeLorean it was called Operation full
circle and involved actual drug dealers
so he's now part of Hoffman's web where
he's getting all these people convicted
of writing and arresting the FBI plan
was to get John to buy coke from a
dealer to help finance the car company
while at the same time getting the
dealer to bring money into the u.s. as a
temporary loan for John so that way they
can get the drugs and the money that
this guy has sure it's a twofer it's a
twofer
John said he want a little entrapment he
mm-hmm
John said he wanted nothing to do with
it and just wanted everything to end Oh
No
are you gonna make him sympathetic
uh-huh John said Hoffman then called and
threatened to kill his daughter quote
I'll send your baby daughter's head home
in a shopping bag where's the bag from
yeah there's a paper I guess I don't
have plastic then it's a paper so it's a
paper bag you got to wrap it yeah and
some kind of some tissue cause that's a
crowd would you like a soup I would do
like a zoo bars I don't even know what
zoo bars is but I'll do it yeah I mean
or I mean you just do it like a normal
grocery store I'd love an Albertsons one
yeah I mean one of the classy ones oh
yeah I'm with you
Oh head so the problem with this story
that John says is that the deal took a
long time to close and so these guys are
meeting for weeks and months after the
call where he threatened to cut off
John's daughter's head right John hung
out with them and they're friendly the
whole time okay so that's dicey yeah the
entire summer John met with Hoffman and
the drug dealer over and over and over
they began referring to cocaine as
monkeys sure well that's a good cover
let's snort a line of monkeys do we that
still tracks the conversations were all
taped everything on it no by the FBI
these guys like in the other room oh wow
every [ __ ]
every meeting yes it's all hotel rooms
that guys in the other room
there are so many FBI agents in the next
room that one time there's cigarette
smoke set off a fire alarm my god
also just too much smoke I know this is
the worst part of the story
just somebody crack a [ __ ] window oh
my god an FBI agent posing as a bank it
was brought in to help seal the deal he
tried to convince the dealer to take
stock or a seat on the board of DeLorean
but the dealer had read all about the
car company even the dealers like I
don't know is that even a thing and I'm
trying to keep my portfolio on the
up-and-up I don't like the other tick
yeah another issue was that John need at
one point a man eight million to buy the
coke okay that's how much the coke is
but he has no money now does he want the
coke to use or he wants the coke to take
the coke in celle Street and have more
money Jesus Christ a good idea but he
has no money so he told the banker then
he has no money and he blamed the IRA
he's likely the IRA I cut down a fairy
tree they've really just placed me even
though John had no money somehow the
drug deal moved forward that's the best
way oh great I still get the drugs the
banker FBI guy offered to loan John the
money to buy the coke as collateral ja
so he's offering for the so the drug
dealer who was selling the drugs to John
the banker is now working in our he will
give a loan the drug dealer will give a
loan to John and as collateral John
it gives him what's left of DeLorean car
parts office [ __ ] Jesus Christ so the
guy buying the drugs is getting a loan
to buy the drug this is what I'm at
Manchester United and when they got
bought and the dough and the Dodgers
right you buy it you just get loans and
buy a team so but this is cocaine right
it's different
so John pushed the dealer to invest in
his car company after the coke was
resold to rescue him from foreclosure
okay Jesus in return John would turn
over controlling interest in the deal
and car company what somehow everyone
agreed what get none of it makes it does
not like especially if you're like I'm
building the come back for the DeLorean
do you want to run it though until then
I mean literally there is no reason for
John DeLorean to be involved in this
right yeah cuz the guys giving him money
and then he's buying cocaine with that
money and then yeah yeah he's gonna
Walter why to come back a boring so it
did not dawn on John that he had really
nothing to offer anyone in the deal but
I made it but John was not handing over
the DeLorean Motor Cars unlimited
instead he was giving up a dormant shell
company with no value that was
controlled by British receivers John
told the receivers money was coming into
the accounts okay so the night before
the deal John wrote a letter to his
lawyer and gave it to someone - oh by
the way the deal he called them up and
he said okay I'm ready to do the Monkees
let's do monkeys dad for the deal John
wrote a letter to his lawyer and gave it
to someone to open if he died Wow
it's it started quote I'm going to LA
tomorrow to accomplish a minor miracle I
will have induced
organized-crime to donate 10 million to
reopen the belfast plant and when they
figure it out they cannot do anything
about it
okay except kill him sure I don't know
why that's not part of his equation but
right as john flew from New York to LA
the deadline to deliver the money and
save his company pass so he's literally
flying in the air when the deadline that
the British are set comes and goes okay
and no money that money he thought was
coming the time didn't did not okay
that's a stressful flight so no money is
deposited okay he lands he basically has
nothing now he doesn't know that though
because it's 80 whatever 182 it's full
of hot women yeah he has to go to spank
ow he can't because also with the two
guys he's doing the deal it's yeah so
they go to a hotel room on century
Boulevard the banker takes out a
suitcase of cocaine
Hoffman said it will make John at least
four and a half million after it's
resold John lifts up a bag of cocaine
laughs and says it's better than gold
that's is that for like the next
Christmas DeLorean there just yeah I
cannot explain gold it's made out of
cocaine three people bought it then an
FBI agent walks in the room and says hi
John
this is all on camera he's arrested on
eight felonies a five million dollar
bail while he's in jail he finds God oh
Jesus he was two cells down he I thought
I met him in the shower
hey what's up I'm God me and God had a
weird thing yeah he's a top yeah
so he ends up selling assets to make
bail including his part of the New York
Yankees okay he spent that Christmas in
Vail Wow sorry jail Vail Oh interesting
yeah different the following summer
Christina and John were baptized in the
pool behind his New Jersey mansion oh my
god that's the best place in New Jersey
to be baptized in our pool I mean that
falls someone at one of his defense law
firms leaked the surveillance tape of
the bust to Larry Flynt oh [ __ ]
Jesus there's a lot of names a lot of
players so Larry Flynt gave it to 60
minutes 60 minutes aired it October 23
1983 so now everyone in the country sees
John DeLorean buying cocaine ayyankali
gold it's [ __ ] devastating but then
because everyone saw the trial was
delayed because they didn't know how
they could get a jury right Larry Flynt
held a press conference at his mansion
sure he played a tape on a boombox and
said it was Hoffman threatening to kill
John's daughter Oh what but the sounds
very bad thankful Larry had transcripts
of the conversation which he hands out
to the reporters so then Flint gets
called into court
and he refuses to tell the judge who
made the tape or who gave it to him or
to even turn over the tape so the judge
gives a little time to think it over
uh-huh so when Flint comes back to court
he is dressed in a bulletproof vest a
military helmet wearing a Purple Heart
and an American flag as a diaper Oh God
how do I not know this part what my god
he had ten thousand and crumpled up
bills to pay his contempt of court fine
oh my god an American flag is a diaper
is quite a statement so the judge
ordered Larry to go down the hall and
count the money in a room and straighten
it out okay later an FBI agent went in
and found Larry sleeping on the floor in
the room larry flynt ended up pleading
guilty to wearing an unauthorized purple
heart in exchange for dropping the
charges of desecrating the flag oh my
god what a compromise we're gonna have
to plead on the flag diaper but uh don't
worry about the other charges so do I
get away with making a boom-boom on the
flag yeah you are in legal terms you are
going to be vindicated from your
boom-boom no thank you
so then Larry admits the tape as a
forgery okay
John's trial started on March 5th 1984
the defense said all the tapes were
produced and choreographed to make John
look guilty they attacked Hoffman as a
paid informant even the judge questioned
Hoffman and Hoffman admitted he would
get a percentage of the value of the bus
if the judge is cross-examining you are
shady the banker FBI agent admitted John
was putting up no money for the cocaine
a DEA DEA agent testified that hoffman
had made this all happen and then he
cried on the stand when it was revealed
the government had ordered his mentor to
testify and just try to describe
him Wow christina sat behind John and
support everyday once the judge
admonished her for mouthing swear words
at witnesses that's how you do it
that's how you do it in a courtroom the
defense's closing argument was so good
it ended up in a book called greatest
closing arguments in modern law whoa
they found a John not guilty John
shouted quote praise the Lord
Christina left John three weeks after
the trial oh my good
what Jesus so she was rooting for jail
she was a goat yeah the dealer in the
hotel room with DeLorean flipped on
everyone
and helped take down Pablo Escobar and
the medine cartel holy [ __ ]
a year later John was indicted in
Detroit on fraud and racketeering
because of all that money that had
disappeared from investors at the very
beginning right he was found not guilty
on all fifteen counts in 1985 Back to
the Future was made the DeLorean appears
in the movie as a car that can travel
through time the movie was incredibly
successful and so the car is now more
associated with Christopher Lloyd and
Michael J Fox than John DeLorean John
declared bankruptcy in 1999 his New
Jersey estate was bought by a group who
then sold the to Donald Trump who turned
it into a golf course his daughter
Ivanka was married there oh my god John
kept talking about making another car
he created a watch line called DeLorean
time they were motion powered and cost
three thousand four hundred and ninety
five dollars well I mean and you never
see someone without one of those now
let's imagine the world without the
DeLorean time the motion-activated watch
each purchase included getting on the
waiting list for his new car so the
watches were never manufactured Oh John
died soon after of a stroke on March 19
2005 he had been living in a New Jersey
condo on Social Security for a decade GM
declared bankruptcy in 2009 it was the
fourth largest bankruptcy in US history
in 2018 GM announced it was laying off
or transferring 14,000 workers and 25%
executive staff holy [ __ ] that's normal
story I mean I really thought I knew
some of that I knew he got in trouble I
knew he made the DeLorean everyone is
right and I assumed that he had gone to
jail yeah I thought he'd gone to jail he
didn't he was totally just falls off the
map it was totally obviously entrapment
I mean yeah so it's totally I mean it's
entrapment on like a few different
levels yeah it was a [ __ ] disaster
you know the thing he probably did
reading through stuff it sounds like he
did fraud of people and he got away with
that yeah cuz that a lot of that money
like he ended up buying us like some
sort of snow-clearing company with like
millions of it like shady as [ __ ] right
like the movement of money but he got
away with it
Wow a little tale you've got there David
I have I have tons of wild little tales
shut up they call me wild tale guy down
at the club what club that Club word the
history Club yeah I am part of a history
country club
hey we should mention we signed
DeLoreans happy Easter yeah we love you
Jesus